you are now live with layer eight culture
tech thursday all right all right dope
thursday tech thursday what's going on
everybody so tonight we have gabe coleman
Good friend of mine, good brother of mine.
Going to Tech Thursday,
talk a little bit about his business.
It's important that you know how we do
it.
The culture is all about building public.
We definitely want to see people having
these AIs.
They can definitely sleep on that tonight.
And we'll just talk about kind of things
I've been doing, things he's been doing,
kind of bounce ideas off.
We just do a lot here at Larry's
Culture.
So Gabe,
go ahead and introduce yourself to the
people.
All right, all right.
Appreciate you, Donville.
Glad to be with you.
So I'm a, again, a Gabe Coleman.
So I'm a mortgage loan originator.
And I've been always interested in AI and
just technology.
But, you know, with me trying to increase,
I would say,
my footprint here on the Space Coast,
Florida, Texas,
and
reach more people.
I have been increasing my usage of AI
and social media.
Never really posted a lot,
but got to let people know what you
do.
So the best way to put it out
there is using social media and
have certainly been leveraging some AI
tools, ChatGPT, to create those flyers.
I used to get in there and kind
of grind it out on Canva,
kind of got somewhat proficient with that.
But man,
just speaking a little bit to ChatGPT,
giving it a few prompts,
uh, certainly learn how to maximize, uh,
you know, probably not even maximize.
I think I've increased, uh,
my output using it.
And so now I'm just continuing to look
for ways to steal some time back in
the day, uh, spend less time, you know,
having to do that.
But, um, yeah, I mean, that's,
that's kind of the main thing is,
you know, where, where I'm at right now.
Um, I also got a few other things,
other projects that I've been,
been working on as well.
And I think, um,
You know,
using the tools that have been presented
to us are certainly helping make life a
little easier in some of those endeavors.
You can see what you've been doing with
social media content,
especially with the mortgage company.
And probably about a month ago,
it caused some traction on Lariat Culture
where we were going through all your
content and how you go from the memes,
then you throw that into like your
business and you try to push it out.
It's really part of your brand now because
I see it pretty much every time I'm
on social media,
I look at
the next i look at jerks part stuff
more than i do like memes and stuff
like oh where's that come from okay let
me look into it you know i appreciate
it i like how you keep you stay
on brand as far as just being like
hey i'm gonna get some do this to
grab your attention and here's mortgage
information here's a here's like the uh
the real meat that's behind the sweet
treat that i'm giving you for sure
For sure.
And I think that's the way you have
to do it.
And that's what the marketing companies
do,
the ones that spend a lot of money,
have a bigger budget than I do.
They try to figure out ways to capture
the audience, kind of captivate,
make them say, OK,
let's look at this a little bit longer.
And like I say,
also get the good information.
But that's the main thing is for me
to educate people through the process.
debunk some of the myths and um you
know using social media is a is a
good way uh to do so you know
sometimes you don't you kind of wonder if
your post reaches uh people but you know
you have to be okay with it even
if it lands in a in a few
um you know on a few screens and
they learn something to me that's that's
impactful right there you know don't need
the thousand likes or the viral um
videos or posts but just ones that can
make an impression on somebody to teach
them something that they didn't know too
that's where we get into like how ai
helps with that consistent consistency
like you mentioned like we got we don't
have we have but so much time within
the day so it's important that we're able
to leverage ai in what we do so
let me share my screen for sure get
into it
And while you're doing that,
I just wanted to say I've been jamming
out to some of that Layer Eight lo-fi,
so it definitely kind of helps me lock
in.
We had a regular one,
and we had a, what was it?
We're getting the UK one.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just promised other people following
the day,
but I've been telling the people that I'm
going to the pro version.
And I did, I did pull the trigger.
So I must say,
I've been doing the image generation,
the social media content generation with
GPT image too,
but doing it from the API.
And every time you hit the API with
your codes and generate an image,
it does take some tokens.
And you actually build separately from the
monthly plan.
But with this hundred hour plan with
ChatGP Pro,
I'm doing my content in batches.
And I could just give it,
like right here,
this is a very close content together.
And this is one font.
So my program that I built out using
GitHub Copilot AI,
creates this prompt.
It creates this long prompt.
But it's literally a prompt of six
different images.
So here is image one.
It's aspect ratio, how it's rendered,
all of the details.
And this is all on brand with layering
culture as far as
The shop is always from behind.
Someone's got a laptop, workstation,
phone.
Like it's very,
that brand is very consistent.
And then, so here's the next image.
And the way I built the program was
like, all right, let's,
let's try with one image and i was
like man i'm not about to use prompts
just one image at a time and generate
this i was like you know what and
it was actually a very bigger task it's
like twenty images that you needed to do
i put the prompt in there and it
took a little bit of time but when
it was done it provided the uh actual
zip file all the images are already named
like very organized nice
All right, here we go.
So that's how the zip file shows up.
Go here.
It doesn't look like that.
But the zip file's all coming.
And then from there,
I have the program ready.
I have some captions,
all types of stuff on the shelf if
you're new to that.
So here's the program.
It's a web app.
This one's locally on my machine.
I can't put it on like a website
if I wanted, or it's a full URL,
but I'll just go in here.
I'll select, you know, Larry Culture,
Larry Culture Radio,
also working with Lean Bank and Real
Estate Zillow.
And based on these files,
this has like what's called JSON.
So the JSON file encapsulates basically
It has a script that goes to the
web,
looks at different tech news related to
AI.
It also looks at Tech Thursday
transcripts, Tech Thursdays.
It'll look at comments,
like anything I'm interested in as far as
AI and literature.
And it curates content for the next day.
So a lot of times when you see
my social media posts,
it's giving information about new AI
models.
like here's some tips and stuff that's all
curated through this process it's not me
actually typing this stuff out you see you
click this button generate this does take
a minute or so i don't even click
it but from there it gives the long
font down here you see it was already
generated earlier today i just copy that
drop it in chat gpt once that file
is done drop the file in here
generates all these, has all these images,
right?
And then, the cool thing is,
it actually upscales the image to two K,
so it's an even bigger, nice resolution,
just a new resolution,
so it comes out nice and quick.
Adds your words to it.
It even has the ability to kind of
animate it, where it's a video reel.
And from there,
I set it up to publish,
and that hits my Post-its server.
The Post-its is open source software where
you can connect your certain social media
channels.
schedule out your posts,
and the AI automatically does this.
I don't have to,
I can move this around if I want
to manually, but it just connects,
it has access,
and it just automatically schedules this
stuff out.
Now what I do is I set it
up the prior day,
so like today I ran those two,
I ran the Aerie Culture and the Aerie
Culture Radio,
and that's basically scheduled everything
prior to that.
TikTok stuff, Instagram.
I think YouTube's on here, too.
It's very, very good.
So YouTube's going to be posted.
So you got everything connected through
here.
Now, I'll say this is the pro version.
Doing it like,
if you really want to automate,
you want to post tons of content.
That's the pro version.
You got a couple different systems.
You got your post-its.
That has to run on the server.
So mine is in the cloud,
but that can run, you know,
local on your machine.
And then, of course, you have like the...
And even if you wanted to not do
the prompting,
connect it directly to an image generation
API, you could do that.
And I really just have this thing run
automatically.
Let's think about prompting.
I did want to save a couple coins,
so that's why I opted to just invest
in the hundred dollar chapter DT.
Use the prompts.
Now, I find that to work pretty good.
Now, for you getting, I would say,
something that,
and I position this to Nathaniel from
USAID Good Luck as well,
you need to schedule it.
I just found out about this probably three
weeks ago.
But DBT allows you to schedule tests.
So what you can do is,
you can have it,
like I have a daily tech briefing test.
Every day, it runs every morning at a.m.
I get my AI news right here.
So these are the latest.
You can go through this on my phone,
get the news real quick and see what
the state of AI is.
But you can also schedule images.
So you can say,
All right, sorry,
I lost audio for a sec.
I'm back now.
Yeah, so I know you were saying,
so you're using,
this is the scheduling feature and now
this is just,
I know you have chat pro,
but is this feature in the plus chat
as well?
Yeah, it's in plus.
Okay.
The only difference with pro is that it
does
it's a little bit faster, like with us,
there's instances where I was like, man,
this is taking forever.
But I have noticed that it's more
responsive in Pro.
And then,
especially with the image generation
portion of it, with Chat, plus,
I think they maxed out at eight images,
which you can actually generate at one
time.
With Pro, man, like I said,
I was able to generate twenty images all
in one shot.
Like, give me twenty images,
this is what I wanted.
and i just let it run we'll know
your stuff okay now that's good to know
one thing i did notice recently was uh
chat actually i still have the plus
version i've been looking at the uh the
plus i'm sorry the pro or the business
uh but i hear the pro is is
pretty solid um
But yeah,
I prompted it to create an image and
it created four.
And that was the first time I had
seen that,
because previously when I would say,
give me an image for this,
an image for that,
it would give me the first one I
said,
and then I had to come back and
give it a second prompt.
So it's kind of moving forward in that
regard.
Exactly.
A lot of times I tell people, like,
you gotta tell, don't ask it, like,
tell chat what you want from it.
You know, if you want, you can do,
it doesn't have to be the same image.
You can be like, hey, give me, um,
give me different formats of the same
style.
Let me choose.
Give me a marker.
Let's do a quick draft.
Let me choose a direction.
We've been asked to ask some questions.
I don't know exactly what I want,
but can you ask me some questions?
So you have all the details.
It'll come back.
So sure.
And I would say another important thing,
especially when it comes to image
generation and that consistency,
a lot of people have that issue as
far as consistency.
Something important to build out is your
brand.
So
going to actually you know what let's
build your you have a you got a
website right i do yeah i got a
i want to improve that but it's uh
uh getapprovedwithgabe.com i'll use this
as an example so
Even if you don't have like a set
brand that you built out,
this is still considered a brand because
you use a lot of colors, imagery, logos,
icons, and that's all part of it.
So we can spin up a new chat.
So please.
I always call it the brand and voice.
And it's always good to use a .env
file.
Because what happens is,
When it comes to this AI,
it is able to read PDFs.
It can read images.
It can read a lot of things.
But the best format is the .md file.
It's the markdown file.
And it basically takes any information it
has on a
image or video and just gives a plain
text,
like the best possible description of it.
So then you can reuse that, repurpose it,
and it stays consistent.
So if you have a brand.brandvoice.ub file,
you can reference that file as you build
out your social media content.
So you can say brandvoice.ub or...
I'm good with the website,
but I'll also...
I guess this is where it's kind of
strange about...
Like going out to websites,
I do the chat interface.
So what I'll do as well is I
like to use the Snippet tool outside the
image and have it read it as well.
So Snippet.
I'll put that in the font.
Let's see what it does here.
And then what you can do,
because you have all the flyers and stuff,
and you want to stay consistent with the
flyers,
you can add the flyers to that as
well,
and that can be part of your brand
voice.
So even to the point of your fonts,
the way you place things out,
it'll pull all the consistent things out
of that.
Right.
And help you build that brand out so
that when you start to build things like
updating your website,
you want to do a business card,
you want to do other things.
the washing material is going to be
consistently the same.
Okay.
Now one thing that I sometimes get
challenged with that I'm most of the time
having to repeat with the version that I
have,
I don't know if it's any different on
the Pro,
is it starts to drift away from my
image.
like the physical picture that I put in.
So sometimes I have to go in and
say,
replace this picture with the actual
headshot that I'm uploading.
It doesn't, it doesn't retain it.
After a while it starts, you know,
I do,
I give it a prompt and one couple
of times I had somebody like totally
different, you know,
and there's other times that I have what's
supposed to be me, but it's, you know,
again, it starts drifting a little bit.
I agree.
What helps with that as well,
another thing I found was these project
folders.
Like you have, I need to do something,
I've been solving all this for a minute.
But having these project folders,
like how I'm working with the real estate
deal lab,
I put all his things in a separate
folder so that when I'm just chatting with
my clients,
all these different topics.
But my normal chat,
it doesn't actually conflict with the real
estate deal lab stuff.
So having just creating a project folder
where it's like, hey,
this is for the mortgage business.
This is where I'm going to talk about
the calendar, the emails, the proposals,
all those concepts that are within that
folder,
it goes on to that context much better.
And when you do sell that project,
let me see if I
Oh, this one,
I can see where I can add projects.
Let me check.
Let me check this.
Oh, here.
Oh, actually, that's right here.
So it's under library, admin project.
And then when you set the project up
in your sources,
this is where you want to have all
the context about you.
So like,
this is where you can add all your
flyers.
You can add
any pictures of yourself that's going to
be super important right and it uses that
data source before it goes and tries to
drift off and try to develop itself okay
okay that's a lot to have a project
circuit and this is available you know i
mean even the free version has this so
definitely plus yeah yeah i've been using
that um i do have a folder set
up um but what i don't have or
what i did not do was
when I created the folder,
I just created his name and like, okay,
I'm gonna throw all these new topics in
there so I could just have a spot
for it.
Kind of like how you were saying,
I didn't take it that next step and
add in the contents to the setting.
So that seemed like that should make a
huge difference.
So you have these options here.
I thought it had Ultra.
Oh I think they changed it.
But it has Pro and then
So you have checked, you can do so.
Down there, you have the effort.
So it's dialed up all the way across.
It's going to take a little bit longer
to reason over things.
That's to give you a response,
but you can go over it.
That's your response.
I don't know,
I can't do it in real time because
it's already stuck on the phone.
Let's crank it away.
I'll show you a couple ideas, though.
So we're looking at
social media content for Nathaniel,
and I've started walking through this,
what we did here.
So,
we're already in that folder structure,
so we already had the brand reports
already set up for him.
with his colors, the logo was in there,
all that fun stuff.
And he said, you know,
create five sample images, image styles,
just for, you know,
just to aggregate on social media content.
So, made all these different images.
Just that long.
Loved it.
I really like this image because the cool
thing is that if you look at this,
I know he's from Florida.
This looks like
any home in the Florida community.
Like you see the palm trees.
Yeah.
You know, it looks like we're home.
This is an AI community.
Did you say AI generated?
AI generated, yeah.
Insane, right?
Now,
did he use like an actual picture of
that particular property or this just
purely, yeah.
It was just like, Hey, these are,
we want to talk about off market duplexes.
Okay.
You know, it already knows that it's,
he's based out of Florida.
Right.
So it's like, yeah,
let me show you those up here to
show you like, Hey,
it's the off market type of duplex that
you want to.
or even if you want to rent out.
Right.
So we really liked how that was set
up.
And we said, hey, let's take this image,
and we pasted the image back in.
And so let's turn this into a character
set.
We have four images, same brand and tone.
We just kind of line them up.
And then we created this.
We've got the first image.
Here's the second one.
Here's the third one.
So right there,
and then you notice it's got the numbers
on the two.
So that's ready to go on social media
at that point.
And then we want some other carousel
images, so generate some more.
So as you see,
the branding is very consistent, clean,
simple.
And then I think from that point,
we just added more.
And this wasn't on the pro version.
This was on the plus.
So we were doing five different images in
one shot.
I think it's pretty good.
I switched over to his,
and now he's got it running on schedule,
where he has it sub-scheduled as far as
social media content,
and every day he'll have some images that
are ready to go,
and then he can even provide a description
for you.
Definitely deal with the system.
Still the same.
Yeah,
I am going to tap into that scheduler
because now I go in, you know,
create like a single one and a single
image or kind of refine it, you know,
go through a couple iterations, then say,
give me the caption that I can just
grab and post.
So, yeah,
laying that out so I'm not having to
prompt it.
And it just, you know,
it being there waiting on me because I
started, I tapped into that post-its.
Yeah,
so I wanna start building that content
and, you know,
start learning the other side.
So now, like you say,
take advantage of those features to post,
comment, you know,
whatever other things that it has.
But I just actually just got logged onto
that last night
Are you on the cloud version?
Yes, yeah.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Now you go through the cloud,
but then there's also net.
Of course, that has the pricing,
but then there's the open source version.
Ah, okay.
You can install it on like a Linux
server or even on a Windows server if
you have a Linux server.
I'd say the most complicated part is
plugging your APIs from Meta.
Google's not too bad.
It's a little easier process,
but the Meta process is a little daunting.
It's a lot of back and forth,
even for me.
But now I've done it a couple of
times and I'm still like, you know what?
I'm supposed to AI and I'm like,
you do it.
That's what AI do.
Ah, okay.
So, cause like, yeah,
I got it set up last night when
you talking about actually when you get,
when you get ready to post and you're
saying, you know, post on,
on meta is when it gives you some
problems.
Yeah.
So when you go in,
you got it set up.
these channels.
So, like,
when you go to add a channel,
let's say I want to add,
and TikTok will too.
But you go to add channel.
Right.
Instagram.
So, mine's connected already,
but if you weren't connected,
you got to go into, like,
the developer portal for Facebook or Meta,
and you got to set that token up
ah it has me seven search way you
gotta copy the tokens back over the post
it's basically authenticate that it's you
and that meta allows you to access their
um wow okay because i i'm right now
working off the uh of the trial version
um and so when i when i went
in last night it it
went straight into Meta,
it gave me like the different pages.
It wouldn't let me connect to my personal
profile.
So I had to use like the business
page that I set up.
But yeah, I hope it translates to,
you know,
if I keep it and go with the
paid version, but on that trial version,
it was fairly smooth.
It just wouldn't let me, you know,
I had to realize it wasn't gonna let
me do the personal profile.
That might be it, though,
because mine's set up on my person's
circuit.
So if you've got the cloud version,
it probably is easier to do.
Ah, I got you.
Yeah.
So it might be a selling point.
All right.
The cool thing is that it does have
a field out here.
Do they have MCP?
Yeah, so it connects the log code.
That's the open crawl.
all that to where you can you basically
have your ai scan use that same api
token or the connection to data and
actually look at your analytics like
what's what's getting momentum what's
posting like what's getting comments
things like that right and then it'll
actually schedule like all right this is
the best time to post it it'll actually
change that up
Yeah.
And then, of course, I have some guidance.
These are a lot of posts.
And I do that intentionally because I want
to build that brand and familiar culture.
I might tone down the posts a little
bit,
but I can go back to AI and
say, hey,
go ahead and set aside what my competitors
do,
what people in a similar space are doing,
what's working for them,
and have it adjust the strategy based on
that as well.
I've done it a couple of times as
far as like,
one thing that I have implemented is,
you'll notice like with social media
nowadays,
you'll have people that do a post and
it will be like comment,
make it like comment AI,
now send you this guy.
I've implemented that in, let me see.
That's lots.
But what happens is I have these guides
set up by AI on their culture.
And then here's the keywords here.
But I'll have posts like probably once a
week where they'll say like this Key Pro
keyword org chart.
And then it automatically replies back.
And this is actually...
through this program called N-A-N,
and that's open source as well.
It runs on the same certain proposals,
but it's just the automation that says,
hey,
I'm tracking your social media account,
and if I see a post,
that has this keyword,
I'm going to respond back with this canned
message.
And the canned message is linked out to
my guide.
It goes right through here.
And that's provided to the user.
So this is another way to add value
in the program.
And I think they have,
have you heard of Zapier?
Yeah.
It was basically like a free version,
open source version,
exactly the same concept.
Literally it's open source,
so you can download this with some server
and start running.
I do a bunch of cool stuff as
far as automation.
Amazing.
That's solid.
So it's a bunch of like, with AI,
I mean,
there's been a ton of advancements as far
as the products that have been sold
all this stuff adds up.
People are building out these
installations and they're open source,
so they're free to be used.
You gotta do a little work to customize
them and get them set up,
but then of course you have AI.
I mean, it's AM,
it's probably Friday evening,
maybe two hours a week,
just going through it,
chatting back and forth with the AI.
I did what I wanted, you know,
being able to test it out,
and then thinking about doing the fourth
one.
Yeah, that's solid there.
Yeah, a lot to,
it's like the more you dive in,
it's like, okay,
there's a lot more that's opened up to
you.
You know,
you got to figure that out and learn
it as well, because you're like,
there's value in that.
Like, you know, with the posters,
I'm like, okay,
I got to really get into that and
see,
um you know how can i combine chat
with that and then you got the you
know nan uh that's another potential
opportunity there to continue to just
connect things and i don't you know
automate them so yes a lot of a
lot of good stuff
So sometimes you click on the activity,
like, say, in eight minutes, like,
it's way too long.
I'm going to stop it until it's retried.
Let's analyze the image.
Now the, the website that I got,
I can't remember.
I think I may have mentioned it when
we were talking last time is that I
built that out on, uh, using canvas AI.
Um, but it's a little,
it's a little quirky.
Like you can't, you know, I mean,
it'll build it in Canva,
but any changes you want to make,
you gotta like update the prompt or,
you know, tell it to update.
It doesn't,
give me the ability to go in and
make edits to the font or anything like
that.
I have to say change opening doors to
new beginnings to make the font bigger and
it'll give me the next iteration,
the next version of it.
So it's serviceable right now,
but I am probably going to look at
putting it on something where I can
optimize SEO.
I think that's one of the things that's
kind of lacking through the Canva
platform.
because it's hosted on Canva as well.
So I just have it forwarded to my
domain name.
Yeah, a lot of times with AI websites,
you like to chat back and forth with
it.
They have what's called a CMS.
I messed around with it a little bit.
CMS.
Yes.
Honestly,
I didn't like it because I was able
to plug it in to the site I
was working on and make changes.
It's a kind of a blog post type
of setup where you can send consistent
blogs.
And the way it published,
I didn't really like it because I would
have to outcry
Yeah.
And then, of course, if you use WordPress,
it has a pretty solid CLS environment
where WordPress allows you to update a lot
of the site that you build out in
their portal.
And WordPress is open source as well.
It's free.
So you're not paying for WordPress.
I'd put a new site on that.
And then Wix is very similar,
where you're just dragging and dropping a
lot of your stuff.
still have the AI build with the Wix.
I'm not sure if you tried to continue,
I was just puzzled.
Right.
That's kind of what I was thinking is,
or wondering if I would be able to
do something similar that I did with
Canva, but do it on the, you know,
WordPress or Wix that may, you know,
give me that SEO and just a little
bit more customization.
So my intention was to see if I
can
prompt chat or claw to give me the
code to build out the website based on
my description my brand all my prompting
that i can cut and paste that code
to like really get it started and then
from there if i want to go in
and customize and you know add a picture
change certain fonts move things around
that i can do that after i have
the initial baseline website set up based
on the prompt it looks like
Techies he does have a ton of plugins.
They have the wix plugin.
They also have a wordpress plugin.
Okay?
That's a just drop for me.
They'll build it You saw the button so
That's an a lot of you do a
lot and a cool thing about how I'm
using a get up cohort CLI it is
it sits outside of
in your ChatGPT or your cloud interface,
but I still have access to all the
models.
So even for, let's see.
I got some new projects.
Oh,
this was that constant engine I was
showing you earlier.
Okay.
So a little intimidating.
But it's a terminal interface.
It's in here.
Let's restart it up.
And then I can basically just chat with
the AI.
I can have it take over my computer.
I actually go in visually to click on
different things, take screenshots,
scan things.
It basically unlocks a lot of abilities
between the AI.
And then, of course, with Copilot,
I have access to all the different models
I want to use Chord,
I can just jump to Opus, Opus Five,
or I can jump to DxSoul, rock,
open six, like whatever model I want.
That's solid, yeah.
And then even like my Azure environment,
Azure has Azure CLI.
It allows the AI to connect directly into
the environment, make changes,
spin up servers.
I allowed it to set up that Post-it
server, like it did all that.
The server started up, installed Post-its,
and it's getting the URL.
That's solid.
I like that.
What is it?
I know some of your,
like you were showing me some of the
content,
some of the images that it creates.
Does it also create videos for you as
well on the pro version?
It does.
Actually, I'm pretty sure it does.
I haven't even tried.
That's it.
Is there no GROK?
GROK, but you got paid for GROK, though.
Mm-hmm.
Videos.
I think even Gemini does the video stuff,
too.
Yeah,
because I forget the name of the site.
I don't know if it was like ARK
or something where they got...
And I don't know what the pricing on
it is, but it's supposed to, you know,
you pretty much have like AI actors,
you know,
like you can choose who you want to
be your spokesperson or your brand, uh,
brand person.
And you just do all kinds of videos
with that, with that image,
with that person.
Big band in Hicksfield, man,
but Hicksfield is expensive, bro.
Hicksfield.
The thing is,
every time you hit that button to generate
something, it's going to charge you.
Like,
I need to cancel my plan because I
don't use it this much.
Like, you see,
I still got two hours of all my
credits, and I think I pay, like,
It ain't worth it.
So I'm like, I need to cancel this.
But a lot of my lo-fi stuff,
you can see I get about,
I think it's like,
thirteen hundred credits a month.
And then every time
I'll do a low-pod,
give you a brother's eye.
I'll generate the image through ChatGPT.
That's free.
I kind of give it some guidance.
I write what I want.
And then, from ChatGPT,
I ask it to give me a prompt
to kind of animate the image.
Okay.
So, normally it's like,
I want it in scrolling.
I want, like, a coffee movement.
And it's just a five-second clip.
And for this five-second clip, it's like,
I'll put the reference image in here.
And then here is seven, seven,
and that's the effect.
But I want to go quick.
It's like five seconds.
Yeah.
So you can go away.
And at the same time,
this is just a clip.
it might not turn out the way you
want it.
It's like, it's hitting me.
So even with like the, um,
the very close to the intro that I
got, like, that was very,
like literally already probably half my
credits.
I'm messing around with that thing.
It's good.
Cause it's reusable content.
Like it's kind of worth it.
If you know what you're doing, right.
Break it down.
And of course, even through that,
I learned a lot about how you're supposed
to generate the image.
I learned that when you have these
reference images,
you literally gotta do like,
one image to start the scene.
And then like,
from the time the camera moves,
you gotta have the next reference image
and tell it exactly what you want it
to do.
And it's like clip by clip by clip.
It's almost like putting a storyboard
together, movie aspects.
And by the time you're done, you're like,
man,
I didn't want it to work in that
thirty second clip.
It's like, okay, I'm in trouble.
It's definitely a process to doing that.
because you need to be careful because it
gets expensive.
And then the cool thing I like about
Hicksville, though,
is that a lot of people might tell
you, like, man,
it's a scam because you can't go to
CDance.
And CDance is, well, ByDance,
which is a Chinese company,
so it's
There's a couple of repos that I go
through to have access directly to the
API,
but there is a way to access it
directly and get to the content.
And I actually do have a CDANCE, like,
I have credits, and it is cheaper,
but the ability to just go right into
Higgs field, do this in this interface,
the way it's easy, it's like,
I'm literally saving, like,
maybe a couple of dollars.
Yeah.
Like, either way you cut it, you know.
But uh,
and the cool thing about Hisco is that
you do have access to different models.
I can use CBAMS a lot for my,
maybe, local stuff, but like the intro,
I think I used Kony.
This thing is a little bit more similar.
Actually,
I didn't pull up the assets here.
There's the assets.
I'll show you real quick.
It's like my favorite paper here.
So that was just like, these two images,
like the first image here,
and the next image at the end,
where it's like, dropping behind,
and you see an animated transformation of
the painting into a very cultural creative
studio.
The main corporate option is to dissolve
away and start creating AIC that fully
forms around the entrepreneur.
Then you can start some electrical
lighting, how it's supposed to look.
Pretty much everything.
The way you want the camera to kind
of move.
And then so you'll have like all these
different clips.
And then what I do is I'll go
into CapCut.
Oh, yeah.
Put it all together.
And the transitions in CapCut,
those are free.
It makes it super easy to just kind
of put it together.
They have a lot of sound effects and
stuff.
You can tell this actually,
this clip had no sound.
So a lot of sound effects you can
get from CapCut.
And then you have a full image file.
So that's it.
I can't even tell you guys.
I just couldn't think.
I know this is tentative.
They told me how I'm afraid.
Yeah, it's true.
I like, I like it.
It's, uh, you got,
you got some fun stuff.
It just won't cost.
Yeah,
I think ocean where if you sign up
for the first time you do this
That's not those.
Yeah.
Use that introductory, uh,
pricing and features and no,
I feel you there.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like that one came through a little bit
faster.
So this, I really got some learning.
You can tell this is a long file.
Right.
But this is, yeah, thirty-three bullets,
and they're analyzing just the website to
kind of come up with a brand based
on what you have here.
So brand priority,
accuracy and compliance, care, weight,
trust, value, conversion.
It's got you here.
And so we're going to get it to
the .
What's that mean?
Goals.
And so it's going to use all its
content here when talking about you.
So it already knows your email address.
It's not going to use your phone number.
It helps people understand what the motor
chambers mean, their life, property,
investment, or transition behind them.
What your brand promise.
And the fourth thing is that because it's
using this information,
it creates that consistency.
Right.
Every time.
Even when we're, you know, doing emails,
responses, it reviews this.
That's the go-to.
So it's not just coming up with stuff.
Well, you can go back a little bit.
I don't know if it's accurate,
but let me know if it's accurate.
It says, uh,
Bill Coleman's mother's on Twitter.
We will say background dating to .
He helps buyers, homeowners,
and investors .
Okay, he's pretty solid.
And of course you could add,
and this was just based on your website
and screenshot.
You could add Facebook, you know,
connected through your Gmail,
emails and communications you already
written up.
So you can understand like how,
the way you speak.
And when you write things out,
so it's natural.
Right.
It talks about your audiences,
your brand values.
It will be a full manifesto.
And then the fourth one here,
it's a .mv file,
so when you take this,
But honestly, you use a card code,
you drop it in the card,
and somebody's saying to you,
you don't got to go through and say,
let me explain myself, you know?
Right.
And to co-pilot to all these different
APIs, you just take the style and say,
hey, there's the file,
that's what you need, and move forward.
Yeah, that's real solid.
It's like you taking your, you know,
I guess your digital resume to different
models, different platforms,
and
It doesn't have to get to relearn you
like chat has already learned you if
you're going over the clock.
So this is, I like that.
Definitely have this as a source in your
project folder.
Let me email this to you.
Okay, I appreciate that.
Yeah,
I'm definitely gonna use that folder
setting feature.
Cause like I said,
I got the folder already set up and
I'm asking it to like,
I'm over there fussing that chat.
Like, man, you know,
I gave you this picture like five pictures
ago, five flies ago.
Why, how we ended up here?
But once I added in there, it'll,
it'll likely, you know,
give me some better, better results.
Oh yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
Yes, sir.
Nah, that's solid, man.
Appreciate that.
The tech Thursday,
it's actually quick plug tomorrow evening.
I'm going to try to go live,
but we're actually doing a free seminar on
AI.
And it's basically what we just did with
you, Gabe,
something very similar at the lab up in
Coke.
So we'll be there at five thirty p.m.
to six thirty.
We'll also be live on Larry Culture.
So definitely tune in for that.
We'll have it recorded if you miss it.
But definitely show up in person.
You can definitely have a conversation on
how to use the AI and optimize it
in your business.
Nice.
All right.
Five thirty to six thirty tomorrow.
Solid, bro.
I appreciate it, man.
This has been definitely helpful.
Always good to get in and for us
to chop it up either way,
but to have a little something to add
to my toolkit to improve efficiency,
posting,
certainly going to take advantage of what
you showed me here.
It's good to hear.
Anytime, man.
Anytime, brother.
All right.
Hold on.
We got a
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, good, bro.
We appreciate you.
Good luck tomorrow.
I'm going to see if I can swing
through.
We got a couple things going on up
that way tomorrow,
so I may be able to drop in
on the first first fifteen,
thirty minutes of it.
All right, bro.
Thanks for joining.
Yes, sir.
Appreciate you.
All right.
Check Thursday.